foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
this is the Ramsey show where America
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money I am Ramsey
personality Rachel Cruz hosting the show
today with next to me fella Ramsay
personality Ramsay show co-hosts and
smart money happy hour co-host that's
right of the new podcast George camel
wow what a day Rachel good to be here we
launched a new podcast yesterday called
smart money happy hour and George and I
are sitting down having you know friend
a friend conversations about things
going on in the world that revolve
around money yes but we thought let's
just put a microphone
you have a mixed drink and just enjoy
the conversation and you all get to
listen in it's what we would talk about
off mic but instead they're like let's
record it and see if people enjoy this
and the good news is they have they love
it one person said it was like Regis and
Kathy Lee so I am like the old
curmudgeonly soul and you are Catholic
you're not Ryan Seacrest you are no I'm
racist which I appreciate that I'm a
little more radius than me Factor yeah
he's a little snark I see that old soul
but the feedback's been amazing yeah and
I just found out we are number one on
the business charts on Apple podcast the
all business podcasts and out of all the
podcasts which two and a half million
podcasts yeah we are number 33 overall
is it 33 now oh I thought it was like in
the fifth 50s we are just climbing the
charts thanks to all of you out there
time in the charts so huge thank you to
all of you who have listened to have
shared your feedback who have subscribed
and followed and left five star reviews
continue to do that how cool would it be
if we're in like the top 10 and the
world was like got to hear some of this
money message that is so desperately
needed out yeah well and that was part
of our thought of doing that is here on
the Ramsey Show which we're about to do
is take calls from everyone Across
America and the world really uh in
regards to their life and their money
and we get really tactical but we
thought man if someone doesn't really
like care about a money podcast
how do you kind of rope them into this
because we're both very passionate about
helping people so we're like okay so how
do we get the people that really don't
care about money but I want to have a
you know hear a fun conversation just
casually in their car and it gets you
thinking we kind of rope them in so it
gets you laughing gets your guard down
get you thinking differently about money
and that's that's the goal of this so we
got two episodes out right now one is
all about uh is convenience culture
worth being broke and the second one is
all about the TV network that
brainwashed us all and new episodes are
coming out every Thursday uh through
through November yeah season one yep and
see so if you've enjoyed it thanks again
for listening and if you have friends or
family that you're thinking gosh any
kind of rope them in to learn about
money they may not read The Total Money
Makeover or listen to three hours of the
Ramsay show but they might listen to 30
minutes of us yakking it up with a drink
in hand who knows who knows but we're
here on the Ramsey Show today taking
your calls at AAA
825-5225 so we'll start off with Kate
and Philadelphia
hey Kate welcome to the show
hey thanks how are you we're doing well
how can we help
so I'm a new listener probably in the
last let's say eight months
um trying to kind of get a handle on how
to start
um always has kind of saved money but
spent money gave you a little bit here
and I but I don't feel like I'm all
across the board hand stretched wide
open and kind of don't really have a
control on anything but I would say that
we maybe aren't in quite an alignment as
far as being full in family-wise as far
as actually really following the path so
I'm just trying to get some insight on
how to really make that complete shift
to follow the steps to make a difference
in our lives yeah well when it comes to
the family unit you know what the
biggest relationship that you really do
want to talk through is your spouse so
I'm assuming you're married
correct yes and then you have kids
two yeah two and how old are they
they're
College age
okay
okay and a little buy-in from them would
be nice not required at this point right
uh but yeah but you just don't get much
of a say yeah well College in high
school but they will have their say for
sure
um but I don't know yeah having having
your husband on board for sure is is the
key so Kate what's what's probably the
biggest hesitation do you feel of just
like just jumping in and just doing it
all
um just putting that kind of restraint
we've you know not necessarily lived
beyond our means we're kind of middle of
the road on everything but although I
was going on vacation uh purchased
things we want to move you know we have
really done whatever we wanted because
we've had the funds there but you know
we still have been able to save along
the way okay so how much debt do you
guys have
um about 9 500 right now 9 500 okay is
that credit card debt is that car loans
Mr car loan Jessica Carlin so one Carlo
no credit card debts no student loans
just that one car loan of 9 500 okay and
that's the thing we use credit cards but
we pay them off every month so we have
switched to using debit cards solely
except for certain things that we have
automatically coming out every month
okay
okay so Kate I don't know yet not all in
yeah okay so I mean there's there's
multiple reasons why people kind of jump
all in and one of the biggest reasons
that we hear in George correct me if I'm
wrong is they get to this kind of I've
had it moment they get to this point
that they feel like oh my gosh I should
have more money than I do right now or
I'm sick of living paycheck to paycheck
I'm sick of having the credit card
companies call and bombard me right so
like that's a lot of people's stories
and they get to this kind of extreme
point with their lives and they say I'm
done I am done I've had it
you you don't feel like that you're
there okay it's not enough you don't I
don't I don't feel like you have enough
pain so here would be my encouragement
uh doing the plan where you guys are at
debt wise I think you're still going to
be able to enjoy life Kate like our
planet is not that you it is there is a
sacrificial part of this right to get
out of debt but I'm assuming you guys
have some extra savings uh the way that
you've been talking and that you'll be
able to throw at this 9 500 get it paid
off just get some more savings and then
fund retirement kids college uh pay off
the house early you know the steps that
you're probably going to be
transitioning into are not the beans and
rice rice and beans we take calls on the
show with tens of thousands of dollars
hundreds of thousands of dollars of debt
and it's years of this journey of paying
off debt you guys aren't there so I
think you're still going to be able to
enjoy life Kate even doing the Ramsay
plan where you're at
um but also it's like you have to you
have to have intentionality around your
money Kate or you're gonna look up in
five years and be like man we could add
a whole lot more in retirement or we
could have we could have done so much
more but we kind of just yeah there's a
lukewarm kind of attitude for that kind
of middle crowd who's not at this Rock
Bottom which makes sense because you're
not in dire pain so yeah but part of
that is going we're not where we should
be with retirement we could be doing so
much better we worked so hard and yet we
have so little to show for it because
we're doing 17 things at once and so I
think laying out a vision for the next
five ten years when do you guys want to
retire could we retire early because of
our decisions we start making today what
could we do with that car payment every
month if we weren't sending it to the
auto lender what could we do if we're
using a debit card how would that change
our spending and start to challenge
ourselves not in a way to you know
sacrifice just to feel some pain right
but in a way to see the progress like
you've never seen before so hang on the
line I'm gonna send you Financial Peace
University for you and your husband and
the kids to watch that is going to get
you fired up and show you what life
could look like if you went all in on
those plan so hang on the line Jenna's
gonna pick up we're gonna send you guys
one year of Financial Peace University
thanks Kate and again it's AAA 825-5225
I'm Rachel Cruz and George Campbell and
this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America I am at Rachel Cruz
hosting at the room show today with
George Campbell and up next we have
Anthony from Canada hey Anthony welcome
to the show
hey thanks for taking my call how you
guys doing we're doing well thanks how
can we help
hey so I uh I was in the passive uh
income scam with real estate and like I
was there's nothing passive about it so
we like realized we got to sell
um some homes that we have and we had a
house from hell in particular that's
what I had a problem after problem after
problem and it was like
it was like it was going to take my life
um but you know we sold that and we
still made a profit
um so I'm happy about that but uh we
have about 160
000 from this rental property that and
and we have our personal residence and
we have about 170 000 in there so about
300 to 320 000 and we just purchased our
like our dream home uh we really like it
it was five hundred thousand dollars so
my question is what do I do with the 300
to 320 000 do I put a 20 down payment
and then invest the rest or do I pay it
off as fast as I can especially with the
um really high interest rates for
mortgages
um I just I don't know in this situation
what the right thing to do is
so let me recap here your personal
residence you bought for 500 is it paid
for or do you have a mortgage on it you
have 170 in equity
sorry we just we just bought it
um on Saturday and and and so we are we
don't know exactly what we're gonna put
down yet uh if that makes sense oh you
haven't closed on it
yeah we're not gonna close we're very
confident we'll close but uh um but yeah
we have a boat
we have about 300 000 that we think will
have I guess okay we have 160 000 from
our rental for sure okay so you'll
probably have about 300 in cash that you
could put down on this 500 000 home
that's right yeah so why wouldn't you do
that
well I just I I keep thinking about
retirement and you know like the you
know the younger you are the better it
is to have more uh at the at the
beginning to to work on that compounding
uh take that Compound Effect in into
play do you guys have nothing in
retirement
um well we have we have uh we have other
rental properties that we do plan on
selling but the terms aren't up yet
um they're about two to three years away
and we think we'll sell those as well
and have a 200 to 250 and we would want
to put that into retirement and we have
we only have really thirty thousand in
our um uh
uh rsps or tfsas which is like your 401k
yeah sure and uh Roth IRA well we would
tell you to start invest 15 of your
future income into those how old are you
two
uh 28. you've got plenty of time you're
going to be multi-millionaires in those
accounts if you just follow these steps
15 in there let's pay off the primary
residence then you can save up cash and
buy rental properties in cash in full
and that will create all of the passive
income if that's what you want to do and
if you don't want to be in real estate
you can sell those get out and use all
that income and start building real
wealth once your homes paid off that's
baby step seven you can increase that 15
and really start to ramp up that wealth
building yeah Anthony I totally hear you
on the compound interest I mean I was
taught at like seven years old to look
at charts to see what would happen if
you invested in 18 years old versus 38
and all of it so like I totally hear
what you're saying and the sentiment is
great because the math for sure is on
your side when you start early so we're
not saying not to start retirement I
would definitely put money in retirement
but there's also something to be said
when you don't have a house payment and
this 300 000 to a 500 000 house gives
you guys a massive head start and
working to pay that off while still
funding retirement like George was
saying but there's something about
Anthony when you don't have any payments
like when that when your primary
residence is paid for and you guys are
get out of this whole rental thing and
all of it right and and you have no
payments your income is freed up so much
that you guys then can double down and
say hey we're gonna throw even more at
retirement than 15
uh or we're going to take some of that
like George's saying if you still love
real estate yeah let's go let's go find
you know a cheap house and and start
there with all cash and get that passive
income going and all that right you can
start playing with all this because you
actually have money and you have the
freedom and that's something else that
doesn't get put into an equation or that
you won't see on a chart is just the
mental margin that you're gonna have in
your life and the peace and so much when
you don't owe anyone anything it just
frees you up so much so so I hear what
you're saying about the compound
interest that's what we teach here so we
still want you funding retirement 15 of
your income
um but man I would I would put a chunk
towards that towards the house for sure
and that's part of your retirement plan
right I would put on I mean if you guys
are out of debt within a fully funded
emergency fund every other Penny I would
throw into this down payment so you
could go that hardcore and then I would
say George and I may differ a little bit
on this if you wanted to take a little
bit and and and enjoy I would take some
and be generous with like you know it
doesn't have to be this legalistic all
300 has to go at the house but I do want
you guys to like do the math on that
side that if you did put all 300 how far
ahead you would be and how quickly you
would pay off your house how much
interest you would not be paying when
you don't have a house payment like play
with the numbers uh but I would say if
you want to take a little bit and be
generous maybe enjoy you know some of it
too because baby steps four through
seven we always say is you know your
foot's off the gas you're not hardcore
sacrificing you can enjoy life uh but
man there's there's a gift that you guys
are ready to get of three hundred
thousand that you can throw it off
what's your income Anthony household
um well we just had a baby so but
congratulations absolutely thank you
um so when she's back to work in a year
it'll be about a hundred and eighty
thousand amazing so then you go well how
quickly could we pay off a 200 000
mortgage making 180. if we didn't have
any other parents and that gets you
fired up because you're focused on that
one thing instead of dealing with 14
different properties and they all have
mortgages on them and you're hoping the
renters pay and you're hoping there's no
issues and like you mentioned this is
not passive income so I'm glad you
called that out for all of the people
out there who are trying to get into
this real estate business and we love
real estate around here it's a great
investment when it's done right but
there is no such thing as passive income
it just doesn't work like that in real
estate because of what you mentioned
there's you got to hope the renter pays
you got to go deal with the HVAC there's
always someone to uh to have to go up to
and go all right what's the issue how do
we fix this and you guys are in this
business Dave has been dealing with this
for years and he's been rallying against
this this get rich quick scheme of
passive income through real estate I
know so it's a lot of work and it's a
huge huge financial Endeavor and it's a
lot of work when you pay cash for it
right so like even when you go out and
say I'm going to be a landlord it sounds
like oh that's so easy you just put
money in the house and then you just get
money back from rent that's so easy no
you're dealing with people constantly
like it is it's almost this like
part-time job so it's wonderful and and
I love real estate and I think it's
amazing uh because there is a beautiful
thing about passive income when you do
it with all cash for sure but it still
work
still work George yeah it's good but
thanks Anthony thanks for the call good
reminder there so I love that Anthony
they just had a baby
so sweet and it's amazing when you kind
of like enter into these seasons of life
whether you just graduated college
you got married you've had a baby maybe
you're changing jobs like so much of
this like adulting right like doing this
life there's a lot of stuff and one
thing people forget about a lot is
getting a will and so you'll hear us say
it all the time that you need to get a
will it is just basic adult
responsibility and there's no excuse not
to have one and so we recommend doing
one just online it's really fast it's
cost effective and it's a way just to
get it taken care of
but I also get a lot of questions asking
if a simple online will is right for
everyone in everyone's specific
situation so I get that so what if you
need a trust
you know what if you need a mirror will
what about Powers of Attorney what kind
do you need I mean there's so many
questions so our team has actually built
out a quiz to help you find the right
options for you when it comes to getting
a will you'll get a customized you'll
get customized results based on basic
information like if you're married
single where you live even the size of
your estate and you'll know exactly what
you need to do for your specific
situation so getting a will you guys it
is so important so to take the quiz go
to ramseysolutions.com
Wills quiz to check it out for yourself
worth it go do it today this is the
Ramsey Show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five up next we
have Jackson in Athens Georgia hey
Jackson welcome to the show
hey thank you all for having me on
absolutely how can we help
hey I just had a question about I guess
whether or not I should look to rent or
buy right now I'm I'm 24 living with my
folks and uh wasn't
not in college no debt and I make about
72k a year and I was just wondering if
it would be if I if it'd be wise to stay
with them a little bit longer and just
go straight to buying a small house or
whether it would be better to just more
quickly go and try to find a rental yeah
it's a great question Jackson do you
think you'll be in Athens for a while
for the foreseeable future
I think so I think for the uh
foreseeable future definitely yes
because that's kind of how I base
these decisions it's a long-term
decisions
versus renting but I would want you to
be in a good Financial spot before you
bought a home and it sounds like you're
at a you're you're for sure checking off
some of the boxes and not having any
debt do you have any savings or anything
for a down payment
uh I have about 20 000 right now okay
probably if I stay with them you know
I'm sure I can make that go up pretty
quickly sure but and you know and I
could afford to rent in the area most
things that I see within a 30-minute
Drive of work
are probably like 1200 to 1500 a month
which I could do but it was definitely
cut into my ability to save
so what's your take-home pay every month
um I'd have to say maybe like
it's partially commission based so it
makes a little hard to say but um about
40 maybe 4 800 after taxes and health
insurance and that stuff okay and so we
would say you want that at your mortgage
payment to be about a quarter of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed and so
that helps you determine how much money
you need down that helps you determine
how much house you can buy have you
looked at small homes in the Athens area
to see what they're going for
yes um yeah and it just ranges I'd say
most of them are probably like 250 to
300K some maybe around 200
yeah they might need some work you know
or or maybe less than that if you want
to do a lot of work yeah which I
wouldn't be opposed to but um I also I'm
not married you know so I I guess I
don't really I'm sort of hesitant to
just go straight to buying a home but I
know I always hear people talk about you
know just throwing money away renting
you know so no don't listen to them
that's a crap you know what you're
buying patience my friend you're making
a wise decision yeah and Jackson what I
would encourage you to do honestly
because of where you're at yes living at
home is saving you money
but there's just not a price to
being on your own I mean truly like not
having to walk through the front door of
your parents house
and go into your childhood bedroom and
go to sleep like there is a level of
dignity that happens when you're just on
your own like just simply that it is
your life and so a lot of people do go
back home to save money which again I'm
not it's not like a black and white
issue for me but it gets to a point
though where I really feel like there's
a there's a level of stunts of stunted
growth stunted growth thank you I was
like what's my what's the word I'm
looking for thanks George
that happens that you just don't quite
get to that place when until you're on
your own and you're the one paying the
bills you're the one having to figure
out what's in the refrigerator I got to
go to the store I mean it's it sounds so
small but it just does something so
almost Jackson I would if I were you
I would leave I would rent next month
somewhere just to get out on your own
get your feet wet and just maybe sign a
six-month lease and then kind of see
okay where's life at now and then if you
feel like you're still settled you're in
a job still in that area that you love
yeah that you haven't met someone and
and those plans are changing then I
think investing in a house is great I
mean if you if you can be somewhere for
at least five years uh buying a home is
a great investment and so yeah the real
estate Market's a little wacky right now
but if you do those percentages like
what George was talking about that
formula to know that you're not buying a
house that's out of you know you're not
going to be house poor
um and you can still you know make a
make some Equity while you have it I
think it's great but I honestly I would
move out I'd move out and rent yeah I
like that plan and if you jump onto
ramseysolutions.com you can click on
free tools use our mortgage calculator
to help you get some real facts and
figures because that gives you some
confidence and Clarity it's hard when
you're just going I think I'm ready I
don't know when you go on paper and go
okay I can buy a two hundred thousand
dollar house if I can put you know forty
percent down that'll leave me about you
know ninety something thousand and that
will be at a twelve hundred dollar
payment and that feels reasonable in my
budget that will give you some peace and
freedom and so that's what I would
encourage you to do and then go about
the business of doing that if that means
side jobs and extra income to get to
100K so that you can get here in the
next three years that's great but don't
just jump into a house because people
told you that renting is a sin that's
right that's right yeah so I I would
rent Jackson but it's a great question
and a lot of people are in that
transition asking the same thing so
thanks for calling all right up next we
have Samantha in Atlantic City hey
Samantha welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
well I have started listening to
um total Financial makeover
um I've been listening to the podcast as
well and I am really trying to be
accountable and get started awesome um
my question has to do with the thousand
dollars um The Run don't walk to the
thousand dollars versus getting caught
up on everything that I have this past
due
um I've been sitting for quite a Time
quite a long time you know borrowing
robbing Peter to pay Paul doing this
doing that and I have a good income it's
just been circumstantial it's where I
live is expensive
um you know I have a child that I've
been raising on my own and a lot of
things are coming up now and I'm a
little in a little bit of panic mode not
and I don't want to become dramatic
about this I want to handle it I want to
do it but I'm a little I'm a little
confused about the starting process yeah
that's a great question and you're not
being dramatic Samantha I mean when
you're living paycheck to paycheck and
you're behind on payments and you don't
have savings I mean like that's a fee
that's a scary place to be so that fear
that you're feeling is totally justified
so you're yeah don't don't say to
yourself unless I'm just being dramatic
no you're really not I mean this is a
this is a really serious thing and
you're feeling the weight of that so
just give yourself permission to feel
that because that's that is all
Justified
getting current on those bills is going
to be your A1 so what bills are you
behind on
[Music]
essentially the transmission went
um with no emergency fund in place I am
now behind on the loan on that vehicle
and it's still in the shop
um so I am in another vehicle that I am
renting that I am actually I've had I'm
a traveling nurse or a Home nurse
um I'm a Healthcare Nurse and I have an
on-call responsibility so I've got the
extra work part covered
um but I've been paying for this
additional vehicle to get me around and
um you know it's gotten me behind on
everything uh there's credit cards
there's utilities
um
my son's uh swimming membership that he
needs you know because it's the sport
that he does I mean you know I don't
think I'm current on one thing right now
wow well we start with the four walls
which is food utilities housing
transportation that gets covered before
we pay the credit card company before we
pay the auto lender we gotta get the
swim lesson and yeah the swim lessons
honestly yeah making sure you're caught
up on those four things you got to keep
the lights on and keep the roof over our
head so once we're there then we can
focus on the next priority and that
might mean communicating with the credit
card company and going Hey listen I
don't have money for you right now but
we don't want to do is just bury our
head in the sand and not talk to them
and then it goes into collections and
then people are coming after you so be
proactive with every single bill in your
life and every single lender and explain
to them the situation and go this is
what I can pay and that might mean you
give them 25 that month because that's
what you can do until we can get caught
up and so that baby step one it might
take you a little longer than other
people because right now we're in like
baby Step Zero we're trying to get
current and so that's where you're at
yeah so okay so Samantha stay on the
line um Jenna's gonna pick up and we're
gonna put you through Financial Peace
University and it's going to come with
every dollar which is a budgeting app so
the very first thing I want you to do is
I want you to I want you to write out
your your budget for the month and I
want you to cut everything that is not
necessary out of that to free up money I
want you to look around your house I
want you to sell stuff get extra cash in
the door make sure you cover those four
walls first get current on that and then
look to get current on on your credit
cards and everything else after that but
it's going to require probably some more
income or money that you can get from
cutting in the budget and selling stuff
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and up next this hour we have Kristen in
San Francisco hey Kristen welcome to the
show
Kristen are you there
hello there we go yeah hey Kristen
welcome oh hi sorry about that I don't
know it just there was no noise you're
good no you're good technology
things that are taking the time to talk
with me for sure yeah what can we do for
you so
um I'm wondering if it's the right
decision for me to change jobs
um I'm in a very stable position and
going to something that doesn't really
offer the same stability
um my situation is that I live in the
greater Bay Area and so it's very very
expensive and so
um currently in a you know a great
situation but want to increase my income
and I work for the county and I'm
currently like capped out at where my
you know my income will be raised
um and my husband gets raises every two
years so in order for us just to like be
able to feel like we can
um live in our current house and support
our two young kids and all the
activities I'm just wondering if I
should go to more of a self-employment
situation
um I'm a marriage and family therapist
so I would be going from the county to
private practice and along with
increasing my income it would also allow
me to have the flexibility to spend more
time with my kids and you know take them
to their day-to-day activities and
whatnot for sure I guess my question is
I guess my question is just how do I
prepare for that shift when you know I
have my current PTO and I have money
going into
um you know a 401K with with work but
how do I feel confident in making the
shift and knowing that I'm prepared
financially
are you guys out of debt
yeah besides our house okay and we have
we have our um perhaps probably about
four months of emergency fund okay uh
uh and my husband works for the
government he's done that for 10 years
so he's in a very stable position unless
there's like a huge
um
you know where they shut down the
government again but yeah you never know
uh okay so Kristen do you is there a
practice near you that you're gonna that
you wanna join that you're thinking I
could plug in to something someone else
is already doing are you wanting to
start just from scratch just your own
getting your name out there and
yeah so I'm actually going through a
certification program now where I'd be
like a court involved therapist so the
referrals are coming from the whole the
court and it's essentially mandated so
um you know the work is there uh the the
need in the community is there so I'm
not worried about having to like build
up my practice so to speak
um but at the same time you know there
is the anxiety about
cancellations and just it's not a
consistent paycheck it has the
opportunity to bring in a lot more
income than I'm making
um but
I guess I'm just trying to figure out
how to plan for the money I need to put
aside for
taxes and how to you know invest and I'm
not going to be working towards
acquiring a pension anymore so right
right yeah it just shifts from yeah so
would this be like a 1099 that you would
get instead of a W-2 as a contractor
correct okay well you would need to
weigh the the benefits that you're
missing out on and go can I cover those
now from this paycheck how much do I
need to put away with taxes I would
definitely be working with a tax Pro you
can find one of those at
ramseysolutions.com to go all right I
need to put away 35 of each paycheck and
after a few months you're gonna have a
real good picture of what this normally
looks like of what your income is going
to be is this something that you can do
on the side instead of just jumping and
leaving this job and going straight into
it
I've thought I've thought about that but
as I'm going through the program it
really seems like they it's not
necessarily just a uh you know a
50-minute clinical hour where you're
working with a family you might have to
go to court and be on call and all of
that is kind of built for in the sense
that how somebody would be working with
an attorney
um that that's built into the contract
but yeah I don't think my current
position would offer me the flexibility
to honor and say I need Wednesday off
you know yeah well and I feel like you
know you have enough
experience from what you're doing I feel
like you sound like you you have really
researched a lot on that side of kind of
moving for careers it does sound like an
interesting uh part when you look into
that therapy side of what you're saying
um that it's not just like oh you go sit
down for an hour with a therapist Vin
mom and they and then they leave like
you're gonna be with these families
going through some hard things and going
to court and all of that so so I think
on the money side you guys are good
you're out of debt you have fully funded
emergency fund like George was saying uh
research some stuff with that 1099 talk
to a tax Pro make sure you got your
bases covered there because people do
this that kind of stuff all the time but
what I would look at too Kristen is just
to have boundaries because I know one of
the reasons you're doing this is to be
with your kids more to have more
flexibility and it's easy to let fear
kind of take over and think I gotta say
yes yes yes yes and you take on more
than what you're even wanting and you
end up working more hours and you're
more stressed when you're on your own
versus what you're doing now so that
would be one of my you know just kind of
words of caution just to say you know
hey you know test out one or two with
these clients to know how much bandwidth
of my time
does that take because it does sound
like you're going to be doing more than
just that one hour a week therapy
session you're going to be in doing a
lot more for these families and these
people and I might bump up to six months
for that emergency fund yeah as you're
not sure there may be some regular
income that'll give you some peace as
well and look at the other side if it
doesn't work out six months from now and
it's not what you thought it was you can
always go back you can do private
practice you can work somewhere else you
sound like you're a real sharp woman so
I'm I'm not concerned about that so I
would go for it this is what you want to
do yep it's awesome you've done the
right steps awesome Kristen well George
you and I we've hosted the Ramsey Show
together we now are co-hosts of smart
money happy hour our new podcast
yesterday it's out into the world and
you and I together along with Dr John
zaloney uh have put content our hearts
our souls into the new 2023 Ramsay goal
planner so if you love a goal planner if
you want to know that I want to be you
want to be in 10 functional with not
just your time but even your spiritual
walk your money your relationships all
of that you need to start doing things
on purpose and it's really hard because
we want the we want good results in all
those areas of our lives but that
doesn't always happen because we don't
have the motivation or the tools but the
Ramsay goal planner is all of that for
you yeah we we cover all the areas and
at least the main ones here we got
relational with Dr John deloney you
cover the spiritual side and I cover the
financial side and I think having one
goal in each of those areas for the year
is very doable so you're gonna say hey I
want to get out of debt and I also want
to have better relationships because
we've been very isolated these last few
years we want to have deeper
relationships and we want to focus on
the spiritual side and when you get
those you know we call it a flat tire
when you're not doing great one of those
areas the car doesn't run as well and so
we want you to be well-rounded and have
goals in each of these areas and there's
such power to putting it on paper and
I'm I'm the most techy guy out there I
love putting everything in my iPhone
note but it gets lost in a sea of
digital things and screens versus
carrying around a goal planner wherever
you go reminding you visually of what it
is of what it is and so this is it's a
great gift to give someone your life
that you want to encourage especially
for the guys out there like me who never
know what to get the the women in your
life yeah
this is a win-win and it's beautiful
it's like gold foil on the front cover
all of it it's it's wonderful so they
always sell out quickly these goal
planners we only get a certain amount
that's right every single year so make
sure to go to ramseysolutions.com
planner to get yours and you're right
George I never thought about that but
having all the important things in one
spot written down that you're like it's
here because then I'm the worst at the
notes app I have like yes I can't I
don't even want to tell you how many
notes should we compare it's there yeah
it's how many pull out your phone okay
because mine get lost with my kids and
they like put like sushi Emojis all down
them I currently have 3030 notes in
iCloud how many do you have 95. oh my
goodness
you just threw me under the bus I have 3
000 notes oh you need the Ramsey go
planner I think they're making me like I
need beyond the goal oh my gosh okay
well thanks to everyone in the booth Ben
James Jenna Zach Andrew all of them back
there and thank you America for
listening this is the Ramsey Show
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I am Ramsay personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
Ramsay personality co-host of the Ramsey
Show and co-host of smart money happy
hour with me the new podcast that's out
George camel it's real Rachel we did it
this has been an idea for many many many
months and it's out there now for all to
enjoy the first two episodes of smart
money Happy Hour released yesterday
proud to announce number one in the
business charts number 32 overall out of
two and a half million pods was it 33
last hour it just keeps on moving ticked
up a little bit so thank you all for
listening for your feedback for the
reviews for the five stars we appreciate
it hope you enjoy it have a little
entertainment when it comes to schedule
a conversation and some money while
you're on your run while you're in the
car you'll learn stuff you want to even
know you learned it you learned
something it's like Inception but you
don't even realize you've learned like
this show we give you the facts it's a
spoonful of sugar yeah that's right but
smart money happy hour you know it's
great check it out make sure wherever
you listen to podcasts all right so
we're going to the phones this hour we
have Claudia in Detroit to start us off
hey Claudia welcome to the show
hi there I want you to know I realized I
have learned much from you and your
father so thank you oh well thank you I
appreciate that how can we help today
George I'm not ignoring you oh it's fun
I was just enjoying the sentimental
moment between you guys I love it how
can we help here's my dilemma uh my
mother's 84. she has an 86 000 interest
only loan on her home
um I've been trying to help her since my
dad passed six years ago to really be
tight on everything she is tight she is
not a spendthrift but the numbers are
hard and you know with an interest only
the variable rate it we knew it was
coming right we knew it was going to
raise I checked into last year trying to
get it refinanced and the problem was
she couldn't afford a traditional
payment of a you know a true mortgage
so my question is
um should I take money out of my mutual
fund to pay it off
um you know assuming that then of course
I would First Cash Out my emergency fund
and the savings we have
sorry but you can imagine a single shop
yeah
um
but then I'm like I don't really know
like what would be the tax ramifications
for me like if I take that money out
then where do I go from there
um
is that going to affect me I talked to
her today I said Mom
I could you know you and I could do
doordash where I like I'm truly doing it
but I'm I'm driving she's with me so
she's gonna have it on her income level
right she's 84. yeah
uh I've got three brothers they all help
they all are very good they're or United
but at the same time
you know I don't know what to do I don't
even know what the smartest thing I'm so
sorry Claudia well number one putting
yourself in a terrible financial
position is not the solution so we have
to find more options here you looked
into refinancing is there could could we
downsize her is there an apartment or
condo that we could move her into with a
much more reasonable mortgage but then
maybe the kids can help
I you couldn't find anything cheaper
than what she's paying in the interest
only I mean right now it's like even
though it went up it's 4 38. it went
from 274 in January to now 438 but
obviously they raised rates again
yesterday
so
the problem is with the interest-only
mortgage she's never going to touch the
principal
yeah I believe me I know that so it
seems like it's a good number but we're
not making any progress at all how is
she eating Claudia like where is she
getting where does she have money to
live off of
Social Security in a very small like 260
dollar uh pension okay
so what does that add up to per month so
we're talking 25.50 a month okay
what other bills does she have
so she does have the car and I try to
not get her into a new lease but
um we couldn't find something that would
work for her
and you know how often is she driving
around at 84.
every day
like doctor or grocery store or hanging
out with friends what's she doing church
right grocery store doctor our church
she goes and walks she's very conscious
about staying as healthy
and
active
I think we got to get out of this lease
does she have any other debt
no other nuts okay
what if we could the kids could scrape
together and buy her a used car and we
get out of this lease situation to free
up some of that income and see what she
could afford then as far as housing
yeah that would probably be a good idea
I wish we would have done it before
but yeah that might work because at this
point we we can't just let her do
whatever she wants while we Finance it
because she's broke
and so this isn't she's not that way I
mean my parents are godly people but
they had a major flaw as in money and
they laid up treasure for us in heaven
where it will never be destroyed
and I get totally what you're saying
there's no excuse making going on here
but but taking out a lease at 84 is not
helping anyone especially herself does
she know that this lease is hurting her
yeah I don't think you know you wouldn't
be able to have a conversation without
her knowing that yeah she she knows they
screwed up major on finances
that's okay and we're not here to shame
her I'm just here to help her get out of
this lease to free up her income because
that payment could be helping her afford
housing
right
so what is that payment every month
the lease payment is uh let's see here
the 314 a month so that extra 314 coming
in every month would that help her
afford a mortgage
if we switch to a conventional mortgage
what is the mortgage size
eighty six thousand dollars
what's the equity in the home
is she sold it today how much how much
could she sell it for today on Zillow it
says 130 I would say we clear it by 120
for sure that's what I say
man Claudia I mean that just given her
situation everything
um how terrible this mortgage is
um I mean I I would be tempted just to
sell get her out and free up her life
out of this terrible mortgage
uh yeah fix the car situation and then
look to see okay yeah what is something
just and again you know she's
um you know she's in her early 80s so
she still could have a great 10 years
left right another decade if she's
healthy
um so finding something for okay we have
10 years left you know just just as a um
as a math equation to say okay what's a
what what's a small condo nothing fancy
anything an in-law suite with one of the
kids if she's able-bodied yeah driving
around because because Claudia yes
cashing out any retirement on your end
would not be smart wiping out your
emergency funds and putting your family
at rest which is so generous and I hear
your heart in it is so good but it
doesn't help the situation because she's
still gonna have this terrible loan
still attached to her that she's gonna
have to make payments on but it's not
even hitting the principal so if I were
her and you guys I would I'd sell
everything the car and the house get the
equity and go find something small
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hosting this hour with George camel we
are taking your calls on your life your
money your career your relationships
anything and everything so give us a
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five up next is Jared in
Baltimore hey Jared welcome to the show
hey George hey Rachel I am giant fan of
the show I've been watching every day
um you guys definitely set me up for my
financial life I actually started taking
the course in high school and so yeah
I'm 25 now wow
um yes so I wanted to ask a question
um but I think I didn't really see a
good answer on so I'm looking to upgrade
my car I have a 2006 Toyota Corolla
that's what's up and it's still it's
still kicking but uh it's got 160 000
miles and that's it I'm looking forward
to the future George stop needs a new
car if he's been doing this since he was
in high school he's gonna be fine I was
impressed because it's an 06. it should
have more miles than that so that's
pretty that's pretty cool
okay Jared well way to go man at 25
driving an 06. that takes so that takes
a lot of swallowing your price George
and I graduated high school oh six I was
07.
okay that's all right we're young we're
the young crew Jared you've been
following this stuff since high school
and so hopefully you have no debt and an
emergency fund
absolutely I love it
um and I make about 80 000 a year love
it uh and I have about 40 saved and my
question is I I know I've heard Dave you
know he he tells us to not purchase a
car more than half of our annual income
but it still just feels like a lot
um spending 40 so I was like I was
looking at the market and especially
right now like used cars are still crazy
I know it's going down but
um like what would be a number that you
guys would see just given my income and
how much I have to save and no debt
um how much would you guys feel safe
I mean you're you're right on with your
parameters there but again forty
thousand dollars when you've been
driving an 06 Corolla you feel like
you're you're gonna buy a Maserati so do
you have a car in mind I would more
focus on what what's the car that I
would like to buy and then what year
make model mileage am I looking at to
get it within a decent parameter so
that's how we look at this is just those
ratios we just don't want too much of
your world tied up in a car yeah because
it's forty thousand dollars includes
your emergency fund Jared like is all of
that or is this just for a car
specifically oh no this is just this is
just for a car
and do you have any other upcoming goals
are you in a house are you wanting to
put a down payment
yes that's the thing like that was the
other thing that was floating around in
my head was like settling down and
getting into a house but I mean I'm kind
of in a situation right now where um I'm
dating somebody and we're getting pretty
close to marriage and so like I don't
know if I want to settle down for a
house just yet no no I wouldn't no you
don't need to buy a house right now but
the question is how much of that could
be used towards a down payment
and in 12 months in 12 months 12 yeah 18
to two years from now when you have 20
000 sitting there and you bought a
twenty thousand dollar car
exactly yeah and that's kind of an idea
I've been throwing around they um you're
probably gonna laugh but the car I want
is just another Corolla system yes right
you don't laugh at that that was nice I
love Toyota I was driving a Honda Civic
and my dream was a Honda Accord that was
me really dreaming big that's great and
it's a I mean that's a great car so have
you seen what those cost
yeah so I wanted the new crossover that
they made uh and I think they start at
around 30
um for brand new but obviously like I
could get the I think they're they're
pretty new so I mean I think the oldest
I could get is like a two-year-old used
one I think those run between 30 and
35 but like I said you know the used car
Market's kind of crazy but would you
guys recommend spending less like you
said in saving some of it it just
depends on how so if you have no current
plans to get into that house and
obviously you have that savings muscle
built up so when it comes time for you
to get that down payment I think you're
gonna do it really quickly and so I'm
not as worried about that I think a
thirty thousand dollar car is reasonable
for how hard you've worked and how
diligent you've been so the what I don't
want you to do is feel guilty after you
buy it and have you know buyer's remorse
because you've you've earned this man
you're doing it the right way
hey can I get it for 30 instead of 35
let me try to really do my research do
my due diligence and find that that
quote deal and of course make sure you
get a pre-purchase inspection uh and
don't fall for any of their warranties
and fees and all these things are adding
on yeah because the hard thing is even
if the brand new one's 30 so much of the
markup right now still within
dealerships is still insane so
um yeah finding something that is
reasonable probably used
um how much do you think you can get for
your for your current car
yeah you know I thought about that too I
mean it's in pretty good shape I looked
at the Kelly Blue Book I mean I think
it's like around 6 000 so right which is
awesome yeah which makes you're gonna be
spending you know 24 to 28 on this thing
out of pocket
yeah true so that'll make you feel a
little bit better about it but I I would
not feel guilty you're still gonna have
money left over for a down payment that
you can then stack on top of that you've
done this thing so well man you're just
a like the poster child of what it looks
like to follow these steps early well
done Jared some people take the high
school class and they just laugh at us
make fun of us don't listen oh yeah go
rack up a bunch of debt and you Jared
you listens and now you get to go by you
reap the new car because you have no
debt you have a fully funded emergency
fund and you are just killing it it's
awesome all right up next is Sabrina in
New Jersey hey Sabrina welcome to the
show
Hi how are you guys today we're doing
well how can we help
um I just recently moved back home
um I was in a pretty bad relationship
and we were living together and I moved
back home well like six weeks ago or so
I just got a job but I have so much debt
um I have student loans
um foolishly I got two cars and both of
them went into repo
um I have a couple credit card bills
some things and Collections and I owe
some family members
um and I don't know where to start and I
don't know how to manage and it's a
little overwhelming
um and I just wanted to see
how and where to start essentially
well kudos to you for moving back home
and getting out of the situation you
were in it did not sound good from how
you described it so I think that's
that's a remarkable really courageous
step that you've done and yeah and I'm
excited you called because it kind of
feels like this
Fresh Start for you right
um from that side and to say okay I'm
ready to get my my money in order for
the first time ever so can you give us
some numbers Sabrina of where you're at
I know you said you had a lot of debt
you just listed them out do you have
specific numbers for each of these
um not all of them I have about 112 in
112k in student loans okay
um uh the two cars just went to repo
like maybe two months ago I haven't got
letters to see how much I owe on how
much roughly do you think it'll be
maybe 10 to 15 each okay
um uh my credit card bills I have 4 000
in credit cards
um I owe family members around 8K okay
um and collections I don't necessarily
know exactly how much but I know it's a
ballpark around two around two thousand
are those is that credit cards that the
things that are in collections
no
um the apartment I'm sorry the home that
we were renting was in my name
um and he stopped paying bills and
things like that and because it's in my
name you know yep you get the brand out
of somewhere yeah so what are you making
with this new job
uh 70. great okay and is it in your
field of the degree that you got
um essentially I have
um
a master's in public health but I'm I'm
I'm in the health care field but more in
in auditing capacity okay cool
um do you have any savings Sabrina any
cash
just in the bank no no okay okay so what
we teach to start out your very first
goals I want you caught up on anything
so I want you dealing with the
collections aspect
um looking to see okay where can I throw
any extra money to just get this house
out the 2000 I want it out of your life
because you're not connected to that
life anymore and I want you out of that
as soon as possible and it's one of the
lowest on the list which is great and
then your next goal is to save up a
thousand dollar emergency funds and then
after you do that you're gonna list out
all of these debts smallest to largest
So You're Gonna Knock Out the credit
cards You're Gonna Knock Out the family
loan you're gonna deal with the car
loans after that and then you're gonna
knock out that student loan and with
your income it's gonna take you a little
bit but I want you to get an extra job
Sabrina and I want you to go crazy hold
on Jenna's gonna pick up she's going to
give you a 12-month membership to
Financial Peace University which has
every dollar a budgeting app to walk
through it good luck Sabrina
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
with health care costs Rising learn how
Christian Healthcare Ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show up next
we have Michael
in Canada hey Michael welcome to the
show
hi thank you for taking my call I really
appreciate it yeah absolutely Michael
how can we help
uh yeah no so um I am
um a millionaire
um and uh recently uh my mom passed away
about a couple months ago and I'm not
sorry
yeah thank you I appreciate that um yeah
so I'll be inheriting
um about 500 000 and just trying to
decide what to do with that
um yeah
wow well sorry to hear about your mom's
passing it sounds like good money
management uh runs in your gene pool
which is really cool to see that she
left that kind of legacy
yeah well we grew up really poor so I
you know it was just um I think we
because we grew up poor we were just
kind of uh you know learn to manage your
money better kind of things yeah
absolutely you guys have changed your
family tree so five hundred thousand
dollars what is your next money goal
where are you at in the baby steps
uh I guess I'm I have no debt
um and just the mortgage
um my personal mortgage real estate I do
have business
um real estate as well and there's debt
on that but that is a new company and so
it's managed differently okay what's
left on your personal residence
about 545 000. oh wow so you could
almost knock this thing out do you have
cash in the bank on top of that
I do yes how much
uh so
um
personally about uh 20 000 no actually
with uh thirty thousand is that beyond
the emergency fund or is that included
that's including the emergency fund and
then uh beyond that would be just that's
20 000 in a checking account okay so I
mean if I'm in your shoes I'm throwing
that most of that at the mortgage I mean
of course there's only three things you
can do with this money give it save it
and spend it so I would look at giving
some of it with generosity I would look
at you know spending some of it and
enjoying it and then I'd look at
throwing the rest of it at the mortgage
to clear this this thing what's your
mortgage payment every month
uh 2400 a month yeah think about that
coming back into your life in the next
probably the next six months you could
have a fully paid for house what's the
house worth
uh about 845. wonderful and then what do
you have in retirement
um so I guess like the um so I have nine
rental properties so that's kind of
towards our retirement and Legacy
planning
and then in Canada we have rsps and
tfsas
um so
um I have about 250 000 in that my life
has about 200 000 and then we have our
business accounts so in routine earnings
she has about 275 in her account and I
have about 73 000 in the end of their
account wow and
um yeah so just kind of so I was just
wondering do I I I've gotten wealthy
through the real estate business I mean
I work as well so it's kind of something
because we were poor I just started
investing when I was 25 years old and
just kind of it's amazing you went hard
and nobody else right yeah so
um so basically I'm like real estate is
kind of where I'm comfortable like
investing
um outside of you know whatever's in the
rsps and things like that sure so it was
just kind of like should I buy more real
estate as a rental so that you know for
my retirement savings
um Legacy planning you know kind of
building my own pension kind of thing
are the nine rental properties that you
have Michael are they all paid for
no they're
um they are leveraged they're about 40
debt to equity so I have about 2.91
million dollars in real estate of that I
owe about 1.185 so I have about
1.725 million in equity in those yeah
yeah that's great I would still focus on
the personal and start paying off that
primary residence and then I'd work my
way paying off the rentals
right I want you to have that kind of
peace
right
okay yeah so that's often actually
stressed by I'm sorry go ahead no no
yeah and I know and you guys are in a
great position what you've done thus far
I mean it's it's impressive
um you've done an incredible job you
have a great income you guys are
Diversified you have real estate you got
uh your retirement you guys are wise
yeah you're feeling good you don't feel
you don't feel the pinch
um like you're saying but I would
encourage you there's just this Factor
when it comes to money and it comes to
debt that it can't be put on a
spreadsheet and there's just something
to be said about this Freedom when you
don't owe anyone anything
and you have complete say over what goes
on and so
um that's that's the primary one of the
primary messages we talk about about on
this show and so it makes us a little
weird because I know the real estate
game and you know you can make great
money doing it but you also have
you have risk still into play
um over a million dollars you know with
the with the rentals even though I know
they're great and you have I'm sure you
have tenants and everything's working
fine but there is still that level of
risk there that you have and so to be
able to use this money from your mom
um to set you guys up even better
um to do things that you probably
thought were never even possible uh it
it's an incredible thing that you can
use this money as a tool to help get you
guys there so I'm with George I would I
would throw it at
um I would throw it at your primary
residence I mean I feel like you guys
are enjoying life like you said you're
like we don't feel stressed I'm sure
you're enjoying life so you could spend
some of it but I feel like you're
spending some money anyways uh giving is
always a great piece uh and a needed
piece in this formula as well Michael so
if you guys aren't in the habit of being
generous this could be a great start and
using some of this money
um that your mom left to give some of
that but I would throw yeah majority of
it at your primary residence I paid off
and just get that mortgage knocked off
and just that freedom I mean there again
there is just something to be said when
you just don't have that mortgage
payment and then start looking at the
rental income so or the rental
properties that you have and start
working your way out of debt on those
and and then the amount of money that
you'll have coming in from not just your
income but not having payments and the
passive income from Paid For Real Estate
I mean it just snowballs from there of
what you can do and that's a that's a
huge Legacy to leave uh your family
because you guys are on the path I mean
you're you're doing you're doing a great
job when it comes to the numbers and I
would just I would I would turn a few of
those knobs and and get out of debt
quickly
it's a good word that's right okay so
George we I feel like we have a lot of
things going on from the smart money
happy hour yep uh that launched
yesterday our new podcast uh we also
have some events that are yeah in the
making which is so fun we had a great
time in Phoenix with two sold out
Building Wealth events yes we did two
nights in Phoenix so thank you Phoenix
that was a really fun uh a fun fun two
nights uh with about 3 000 people each
night and getting able to talk about
Building Wealth which is uh always so
exciting but one of the other events
that we have coming up it's the big dog
is our smart conference in Dallas Texas
Saturday October 22nd and we've just
found that when you do anything big in
life whether it's Building Wealth
whether you're losing weight whether
you're looking for a total career shift
and changing your job whether you want
to overcome Stress and Anxiety that
you've been dealing with giving all of
these things
can seem impossible but when you have a
plan and you know what you're doing it
helps in all areas of your life so
whether you've lost your job or the
credit card bills or eating up your
payments or you're feeling alone in this
crazy world whatever it may be I would
encourage you to come to our smart
conference again in Dallas Texas
Saturday October 22nd it'll be a full
Saturday event yes it does no joke all
day event with Dave Ramsey Dr John
zaloney Ken Coleman Christina Ellis
George camel myself and Pastor Craig
groeschel and his wife Amy they're gonna
be talking about marriage so we're
talking about your money your
relationships personal growth career so
join us live before tickets sold out
before they sell out this is an arena
event and it will sell out yeah
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats today I was joking with John
yesterday on the show that he could say
long keynote did you see his oh yeah
yeah John is long-winded for about 45
minutes George and I don't get that
amount of time but we'll be there we say
more and less time 30 minutes I know but
it's really fun it's a blast hope you've
enjoyed us
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
Ramsey personality George at Campbell
you want to tell them what just happened
Rachel
add a mouthful of chocolate chip cookie
that's right freshly baked from the
Ramsay Cafe over here Baker Street so
reminder to all of you who are coming
through Nashville or want to make a trip
we have guests every single day right
here in our lobby we've created a Fan
Experience you can buy books otherwise
everything's free you get a free mug
free cookies free coffee drinks and I'm
gonna give out mugs yeah we signed one
earlier you saw it I did yeah
absolutely one for family I've been on
an Americano as we speak and a fresh
baked chocolate chip cookie and so
Frugal it's all free for guests and for
Rachel as well when we host we get to
the Ramsey team members they did smell
amazing out there I know tantalizing
pretty fun but yeah come visit us for
sure we're right outside of Nashville a
lot of people that come to Nashville for
just the tourism bachelorette parties
Church conferences yeah there's a
spectrum there's a lot uh there I need
to show you the break but there was a
funny Twitter or a video on Twitter
about it was like this trailer and it
sounded like the guy from Discovery
Channel he's like a deep British accent
oh yeah and he's like a nice you know as
the sun goes down they start to come out
and it's and it's about The Bachelorette
oh my goodness we call them the woo
girls because they're always going
everywhere they go all right oh my gosh
but come to Asheville it's pretty fun
pretty fun it's a wild time it's a wild
time all right go into the phones this
hour we have Alex in Minneapolis hey
Alex welcome to the show
hey Rachel and George how are you guys
doing we're doing well thanks for
calling
yeah thank you it's awesome to be here
thanks so much I got a question
um I am a 20 year old college student I
have no debt and I'm looking to make my
first car purchase I just want to make
sure it's a financial responsible
decision okay
um so the car I'm looking at is twenty
thousand dollars and I have the cash to
pay for it
um I make about 32 000 a year and I have
about a seventy thousand dollar net
worth
um and I'm currently living at home
what do you guys think
you want my honest answer do you want me
to make you feel good I can do either do
both I want to see both somewhere
somewhere in between in between okay
Alex I answer these questions as if I
was in your shoes and at 20 years old as
a college student I would not buy a 20
000 car making thirty two thousand
dollars with a seventy thousand net
worth you laid out all the numbers for
me and I don't I don't know looking on
paper when you go should a guy with a
seventy thousand dollar net worth have
20 of that tied up in a depreciating
asset that goes down in value every
single year that's a lot of your world
and a lot of your income you know think
about how many paychecks that took to
get to twenty thousand dollars and now
it's going into a car that's going to
get bumped and dinged and scratched up
especially at 20 years old that's when I
got into the majority of my accidents
was in that first you know five seven
years of driving so I don't I don't
think you need a twenty thousand dollar
car right now while you're in college I
would wait until you know maybe you're
out of college now we're making 50 fifty
thousand dollars now it makes more sense
to purchase a twenty thousand dollar car
you can upgrade sell the old one and get
that newer one yeah how are you
finishing College Alex how are you cash
flowing it
uh so the first couple years are covered
by financial aid yeah so that's really
nice and in the last two years my my
parents uh are paying for it very nice
how much how much more school do you
have left
I'm currently uh entering my uh
sophomore I'm in my sophomore year
you're in your sophomore year okay so
you have two more years of school yeah
that's great and you don't have a car
right now
no do you need a car on campus
yeah do you go to school there yeah well
I'm just wondering how he's been getting
around myself George how have you been
getting around so far so I actually so I
actually do online school so I work it
from home
family car right now
yeah I'm basically using dad's car right
now okay yeah you need your own car what
kind of car were you looking at that was
twenty thousand dollars
uh 2017 Audi A4
20 that's a nice car it's a great car so
here's what I would do and so could you
split the difference
but the difference could you get a an
older Audi
yeah I could so originally my initial
budget that I had set was anywhere from
about 15 to 20 000 and 20 000 was you
know my upper upper limit
um
I don't know something special about
this car is that I found that I did that
looked on Kelley Blue Book and it's
actually several thousand dollars
underneath the the fair market value or
whatever yeah that's one thing that kind
of tempted me into possibly buying it
but I totally go through what you're
saying it's not an investment so I
wouldn't look at it as I'm getting a
killer deal I'm going to resell it make
a profit you want to drive this thing
and it's going to go down in value over
time so exactly I would I would lean
towards that 50 as my upper upper limit
and that's after all taxes and fees and
also remember this that Audi the repair
costs on those cars is astronomical
so you've got to be prepared with a big
emergency fund to cover when that car is
in the shop
and Alex here's the deal too uh
and I don't want to like blame it on
your age but it is like the season of
life you're in if you were making a
hundred thousand dollars or something
you know then we'd be like yeah go get
it that's great it's be partly because
of your income so we would say to to
spend no more than half of your annual
income on a car so that gets you at that
like kind of 15 16
000 range which you have to cash for
which is great so I would I would look
more there you're not gonna you won't go
into Financial ruin if you spend 20 000
and get this car but what's the what's
the wisest thing for Alex and part of it
too Alex I would really push into which
is not fun to talk about but it's true
it's just this idea of like
of delayed gratification a little bit of
hey I have the ability to do this it's
probably not the smartest wisest move so
what if I did back off and I did
something different you had a little bit
of this kind of almost a self-control
talk with yourself
um
just to say what what if I did something
a little different and then I look up in
five years and go get an Audi that's
three years newer than when you're
looking at now right when you're making
better money but there's a there's a
character building process too uh and
when you can get that down at 20 years
old and tell yourself hey what if I did
kind of limit back and what if I made a
smart decision and spent more like 15 on
a car right now and then fast forward
again three four years we could be
talking something totally different
because your numbers of your income are
going up but you've done a fantastic job
Alex I mean you're in a great position
through scholarships and your parents
hard work of getting through school debt
free you have a net worth of seventy
thousand dollars which is great you have
twenty thousand saves I would just keep
doing what you've been doing because so
far it's working but I would I would
watch it down the car sale a little bit
more and and partly for the math but
also it's kind of a great exercise as a
20 year old guy to be like okay
I'm gonna do something different I want
to do this and again it's not going to
put you in financial ruin but I could do
something a little bit wiser and go a
little bit slower and that patience will
get you far we're just talking at the
Break
um about the fruits of the spirit me and
George worry about this new project that
he's my he might be working on and
patience is in there and there is
something about patients that our
culture doesn't have we want it now we
want it now and that's even the debt
snowball process like when people are
getting themselves out of debt and some
of you listening right now are in the
middle of your debt-free journey and it
doesn't happen overnight it feels easier
to be like oh my gosh I just want to go
take a home equity line of credit and
just get rid of my credit cards you know
but we say don't move your debt around
pay it off like be focused and look and
pay it off and it's a journey and it
takes patience but every time people
come on this on this stage George to do
their debt free screams like you're a
different person you're a different
person something in your character
happens when you take patience into the
equation whether it's getting out of
debt saving up and paying for something
waiting to purchase a really nice car
that you could do but it's probably not
the wisest thing right now like there's
something in your character that happens
when you have patience yeah and I I
practice what we preach around here and
up until seven months eight months ago I
drove a 2009 Honda Civic high mileage
body damage all over and I didn't care
because I had a priority delayed
gratification I said I'm going to pay
off our house and then I'm going to
upgrade in car and I'm still gonna do it
with wise parameters and it felt
different when I bought that car because
I know the sacrifice that it took to get
to that point versus walking into the
dealership buying a car that I really
was a little too much for my income and
just going it's fine I want to drive
this car now yep and so I think that
creates a different type of person it
changes your character when you can have
that level of delayed gratification
that's right that's right thanks Alex
thanks for the call thank you America
for listening and thanks to James Ben
Zach Andrew and Jenna
man there aren't many girls back there
anymore Jenna I respect you thanks for
being here thank you America we'll be
back
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
this is the Ramsay show where America
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money that's right
I'm George Campbell she's Rachel Cruz
and we are taking your calls this hour
the number is
888-825-5225 and we want to have some
fun Rachel and so we thought we'd call
out for stories from you our listeners
on some of the stupid tax that you've
paid in your life the dumb money
mistakes that you regret you laugh about
it we learn from it we've all never make
it again we've all been there we've all
been there George give me yours what's
the stupidest thing you've ever done
with money this is the most embarrassing
I'm gonna go first and be vulnerable
okay be brave I once shipped a pair of
shoes that I was selling on Craigslist
to Nigeria
and I fell for a scam this now this
wasn't one of those like Nigerian prince
games where I thought I was getting a
million dollars a guy wanted to buy this
[ __ ] did you get a forwarded email
forward he reached out and he's like hey
I'm buying these for my cousin who lives
in Nigeria I was like okay it's
plausible that people have cousins in
Nigeria right so you so he was like I'll
pay you extra to ship these yeah and so
I get an email from PayPal that has like
an extra 50 bucks or whatever yeah and
so I went cool and so I went ahead and
shipped the shoes
I later went back to the email on my
phone clicked through the email address
and it was like a garbled spam email and
then I was like oh no so I went to my
Paypal account there was no money in the
PayPal account they had spoofed the
PayPal email so well that I thought that
they had paid me and so I just went
ahead and shipped it oh George fun fact
about six months later I got a Return to
Sender shoes showed up back at my door
no way I guess the address was bad
so Redemption I only lost on the
shipping cost essentially that's so good
that's one of the stupidest things I did
probably about 15 16 years ago a pair of
Air Force Ones or something speaking of
shoes I uh I spent
I'm trying to think of how much money it
was on Tory Burch Flats Millions but I
it was a website that somehow I found
on sale these shoes were on sale so I
spent a few I mean I think I spent a
couple hundred bucks was it like because
I was like
dot net I can get a yeah I mean I could
get 100 bucks off and I got that package
and I remember opening and just the
smell of it I remember being like oh
that that and that um smell like Tory
Burch do they look like Tory Birds no uh
I mean they had the fake logo but they
were like hot I mean they were it was
terrible it was terrible so I failed for
that I don't know well we've all been
what's our shoe game yeah but anyways if
you have something even better I'm sure
you guys don't know the better the more
embarrassing the better just yeah tell
us we just want to have fun with it so
give us a call at Triple Eight two five
five two two five and tell us you're
stupid shame that comes along with money
mistakes and one of the reasons we did
our new podcast Cash Smart money happy
hour was because we didn't want money to
be this like shameful baggage ridden
thing we wanted it to be fun and so we
wanted to create a casual environment to
talk about money with no shame no no
regrets as we talk about in the podcast
I taught you what that was so there we
go I still don't quite so call us up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll open up some lines for you
all to share your stupid tax stories
that's right all right we're gonna go to
the phones and Clayton in Green Bay is
up first hey Clayton welcome to the show
thank you so much really appreciate you
to uh show is awesome thank you thank
you so much how can we help
I understand the seven baby steps uh I'm
older I've been taught my whole life to
give 10 to church first does the Ramsey
plan suggest you stop doing this and
apply that to debt obviously and debt is
taken care of the the last one is to do
uh to donate so I don't know if we
should stop giving that 10 to church
first and apply that to debt yeah it's a
great question Clayton
um the answer is no we teach giving at
least 10 percent regardless of where you
are financially so even if you're saving
up for your first thousand dollar
emergency fund on baby step one when you
click through even to our budget every
dollar you'll see a mock budget and
giving is still at the Top Line
regardless of where you are so we
believe in that generosity message
um no matter what so no the 10 is still
something that we would recommend but we
would also say too you know some people
go above and beyond even that which
again if that's your conviction and
that's where you want to go like we're
not going to say not to but also when
you give
let's just say half of your income away
we've talked to some people they're like
I just give half my paycheck away but I
still have credit card debt and student
loans you know you can make a bigger
impact with your money when it's not
being sent to the bank and to your
student loan and to your car loan and so
there is something powerful about
putting as much money as you can towards
getting out of debt because it's going
to free up your income to give even more
but that's more for people that are
giving you know uh you know 20 30 40
percent of their income no matter what
they're doing uh and they're getting
behind on their bills so we we still
recommend giving 10 and then uh you can
start to be more and more generous as
you become debt free and have an
emergency fund yeah and Rachel one of my
favorite quotes from you is give a
little until you can give a lot and so
it's okay if you can only do 10 but the
Bible's pretty clear on this if you're a
person of faith if you're a Believer uh
I just spoke on a church on this topic
so I've got the verses up Proverbs 3 9
10 honor the Lord with your wealth with
the first fruits of all your crops then
your barns will be filled to overflowing
in your Vats will Brim over with new
wine and Malachi talks about that again
of how the they'll open the floodgates
of heaven and God says test me in this
which is the only time in scripture
you'll find that yeah test me in this
with tithing yeah and so he wants us to
test to trust to obey and blessings are
on the other side of that that's right
how does that sound Clayton
well sounds great that's what I was
hoping you were going to tell me to be
honest with you because uh I firmly
believe in that and I was hoping that
yes keep the 10 and then funnel
everything else you can yeah debt and
then you'll be able to give more when
you get done with the seven steps so I
really appreciate your answer yep
absolutely that's a great question
thanks for calling yeah it is and this
generosity piece I mean it is it's um
it's a piece that a lot of people in the
financial World they don't talk about
but we say on the Rams show all the time
that money is so much more than just the
numbers in your bank account on paper it
doesn't make sense Rachel right why
would you tell me to get out of debt but
then still give 10 when I could use that
towards my debt you told me to be
gazelle intense right but the issue with
that is as Believers we know that we're
stewards we're meant to manage this
money uh on on behalf of God and so I'm
going God's given me this money to
manage and I want a reminder at the top
of my budget to remind me of why I'm
doing this of whose money this is and so
that's why I love giving coming out
first and even if you're not in person
of Faith you know they're regardless of
what faith walk you you follow uh I
would I would argue too that giving no
matter what is forcing your hand to be
open and to let some go out and that
naturally is going to cause you to be
less selfish and more selfless and I
just believe selfless people
have a more joyful life you know I think
when it's not all about you and that's
our world right now I mean you go on
social media you look around it's all
about me me me me me me me me me me
and when you just have this part of your
financial plan with your with your hand
open and just saying hey I'm going to
give some there is Joy when life isn't
all about you I think you're a better
parent I think you're a better spouse I
think you're a better team member a
better friend a better sibling I mean
all of it and it's contagious
selflessness that comes from that is
really big and again you're not going to
see that on paper but something does to
your character when you live without
open hand so giving always thanks
Clayton for the call
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so opening up this hour of the show we
did something a little different and we
asked you guys to call in uh and tell us
your story of something stupid you've
done with money we call it stupid tax
around here when you made a mistake and
you thought oh that was stupid shouldn't
have done that we've all done it right
we've and so some stories are great
better than others but we have to hear
yours and so we got a call in George
Dylan Dylan here from Terre Haute who's
going to be letting us know about his
story thanks for being brave stupid tax
story Dylan thanks for being the first
one up
well thanks for taking my call
um yeah this was uh this was back um
let's say I was 17 years old and uh
driving in my truck with a couple of my
buddies and I had just got my first
paycheck
and didn't have any any bills or
anything uh like that to pay for so
money really didn't have any uh
substance to me I guess and
um I but what did have good substance to
me was my upbringing of
um giving to people in need
and
um one day we were getting off on an off
ramp and I had my whole paycheck with me
in cash
and I feel so strongly for helping or
wanting to help people that
um I always hate seeing
um people on the side of the road you
know begging for money and stuff like
that well I seen a fella that was
uh you know had a sign and all that good
stuff well
um I gave him my whole paycheck that I
worked for Wow and it was my first my
first paycheck and
um we me and my buddies we ended up
going getting some dinner and we came
back and went up the other
um the on-ramp to get back on the
interstate to go home and we seen that
guy uh getting into a really nice SUV oh
no oh boy yeah so this was like a scam
artist
yes
and unfortunately for me I still will
say a prayer for everybody who is in
need but that is on the side of the road
like that but as a lesson and a very
hard
hard lesson learned for me
I do not give to anybody who is on the
side of the road especially nowadays
when you can just turn your head and see
you know help one of signs anywhere
wow you know yeah sure oh that's right
how old are you now Dylan
I am 30 years old so this is 13 years
ago and it still haunts you to this day
well wow it's it's you're a super tech
story though it was out of just the
heart of generosity George and I wanted
nice shoes basically as well this is a
very different motive Dylan's assault of
the Earth yeah it was so good but that's
a good lesson though and I've heard yes
how much was that paycheck Dylan
um it was about 275 oh man
wow and till this day whenever I take my
kids out to go out to dinner or
something like that
um
you buy food or you buy something
I tell them we they because they ask me
can we give them a little bit of money
or something like that I said no we
can't but what we can do we can pray for
them that they have a better life or
that you know
you know God could give them the
willpower to help better their lives
yeah for themselves for sure
and Dylan thanks for calling in that's
that's a heartbreak though because you
especially when it's the motive of
I'm gonna help someone and then man
take off on in a that'll burn in a
Suburban you know that is a worry
whenever you see folks on the road well
that's a good discussion I hear about
these scams just like I know I know and
that's what's so hard and and I always
kind of balance it with like you know
obviously if you feel this conviction to
give in that moment you know I'm not
gonna tell you that God's Not Gonna use
that but also to be wise about it right
is it is it food that they need is it
bottles of water is it like what are
things that you can give in those
moments not just cash because at that
point you have no clue what's going to
happen there or do you give to
organizations you know like the
Nashville rescue mission is one of my
favorites they do great work they do
incredible work right and so kind of
plugging in we're just talking about
generosity in the last segments that's
kind of even bleeds over to it but uh
yeah Dylan that hurts hey I always try
to do the water bottle on a hot day here
in Tennessee no even if they're a scam
artist it's a hundred degrees and
they're just standing out there anyone
can take a bottle yeah absolutely
absolutely well thanks Dylan and you
guys if you have a story of some lessons
learned with money we'd love to hear all
right up next we have Justin in Dallas
hey Justin welcome to the show
hey there can you guys hear me all right
yeah yeah a little bit a little bit my
foot a little bit noisy I think we got
it
is this better no that's even worse
somehow all right there we go okay we
got somewhere
sorry
um all right I I'm really looking for
some kind of encouragement guys uh
I have gone through the beginnings of
the baby steps before I went through
maybe step one I was like halfway
through baby stuff too and then uh and
then a whole bunch of stuff happened I
lost my job and then I sat around
feeling sorry for myself and it didn't
work as hard as I probably should have
and ended up taking him out or phpa loan
and now I feel like I'm more in the
whole than I ever have been before
yeah and I'm just every time I see I
watch a guy show like every day
so inspiring
um
I see that that pre-screens people do
and I know I want that for my life
and I just don't know
I don't believe that I can do it you
know
Justin it there is hope for you yet my
brother I know when life punches you in
the face that many times you just feel
like well I guess this plan isn't for me
it's for other people it's for people
with less problems and more money
but I'm telling you man this pla Bliss
plan was especially made for people like
you and so there is hope and if there's
any resources we can send your way if
there's any cheerleading we can do for
you to tell you that you can do this we
are here for you today
yeah and Justin I think one of the the
biggest things in your situation is I
feel like even you you know mentioning
the payday loan and oh I was that and I
felt sorry for myself you know the even
the wording the verbiage you're using in
the call
it feels like you have a lot of Shame
around this topic which is very normal
money is like this thing that just
stares at us right in the face and it is
so easy to get in the cycle of Shame and
sitting in your regrets but Justin
that's in the past those things yes
you're going to have to face in order to
move forward but that does not have to
determine what you're going to choose
today and that's the beautiful thing we
all all of us get to wake up every
morning and decide okay what decisions
am I going to make today and we can
either make decisions that end up
harming us in the future or that help us
in the future and everyone's story looks
different Justin so your story is going
to look different than another debt free
scream call on here or another call we
take later in the show because depending
upon you know even your mindset right
and and what has been spoken into you
throughout your life what you believe
about yourself to the actual numbers and
the debt levels and the income levels I
mean all of it's going to look different
but we are all we are all people and we
all get to make decisions and Justin I
believe that you can because we've seen
it all Justin we have seen every story
imaginable on the show and so I would
love to see real quick before we we
gotta we gotta have we have a heart out
here in a few minutes in a few seconds
but
um we want to be able to give you
Financial Peace University so Jenna's
gonna pick up and watch these nine
lessons Justin okay and listen it's not
going to be perfect okay you're not
going to be perfect with it it's not
going to be like oh one day I'm gonna
watch these videos and know life's gonna
happen and I'm gonna make every right
decision yes your trajectory hopefully
is going up but it's going to go a
little bit down up down up I mean you're
gonna feel it right it's not gonna be
the straight line going forward
but the decisions you make going forward
are going to be so important but it's
going to be okay because you've got this
you can do this and Justin join a local
class I want you in a community of
people who are cheering you on because I
can't be there in Dallas Texas to do it
for you so join a local class when we
sign you up for FPU and I want to see
you on the stage and I'm gonna remember
Justin from Dallas who thought he
couldn't and you're going to inspire so
many people who feel exactly the way you
do right now I can't wait to see what
the future holds for you brother thanks
for calling
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's question from blinds.com
blinds.com 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they will remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promo codes
that run every month you'll save even
more use promo code Ramsay to get the
best deal today's question comes from
Rhonda in Idaho
I followed the baby steps so that I have
no debt in a three-month emergency fund
however I'm saving for a house currently
renting and only have ten thousand
dollars saved saving a twenty percent
down payment seems so unattainable when
putting fifteen percent toward
retirement can any of the 15 be used to
fund down payment since a house is an
investment
it's a great question Rhonda and what
you're talking about is baby step 3B so
once you're out of debt with the fully
funded emergency fund 3B is saving up
for a down payment now three B and 4
which is investing fifteen percent to
retirement they can be a little squishy
and so it's kind of a Choose Your Own
Adventure depending on your age your
goals and so we don't know Rhonda's age
we don't know she's 55 or 25.
but you can split the difference and go
hey I'm going to invest up to the
employer match in my 401k and the rest
is going to go towards aggressively
saving for the down payment some people
pause investing entirely which is okay
for a season I would not go more than
about two years or so pausing investing
to aggressively save up for the down
payment
I would say too we're under 20 is ideal
because you avoid PMI but even if you're
a first time home buyer I mean five ten
percent down payment could work as well
so you can even shift that 20 down if
you wanted to to get in faster but again
you'd save a lot of money if you hit
that 20 so it's a great question I don't
know what home prices are in Idaho but I
feel like they'd be more reasonable than
in some other parts of the you know
country you would think right you would
think you would now maybe it's if it's
in
um I don't know where what's the biggest
city in Idaho do you know Boise
is that right I don't know what do we
think I was hoping for James to be our
like Jeopardy guy but he's he's nowhere
to be found it's fine Boise Idaho I'm
going for it sure I'm gonna say it okay
we're going to the phones this hour AAA
825-5225 and up next is Jackson in
Wichita Kansas hey Jackson welcome to
the show
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call absolutely how can we help
uh well I just want to start off by
saying I've only been uh part of the
Ramsay
um podcast or I've only started
listening for about a week so I'm brand
new oh nice well welcome a lot of
everything welcome to this crazy crew
that you've joined it is it is crazy
um and I just my question it's not
really it's a question but not really
but my me and my wife just kind of feel
stuck right now
um and I'll give you some context about
in may we bought a house in Kansas we
moved from Nebraska around the Lincoln
area and we decided to go buy a house
um uh fresh out of an apartment
um and we made it down here and we just
we don't really but it's not what we
imagined uh you know I'd say that it's
not really what we thought it was going
to be like and now we're we're in debt
uh and my question I have a couple
questions kind of what we should do is
should we sell the house move back to
Nebraska because we have family there
and we we love our family and we miss
them most of all and that's kind of what
we what we are striving to get back to
is our family uh we're really close to
both of our families
um we're trying to figure out if we
should stay here for two years to not
have to pay that
um that tax for not living in a house
for two years or whatever it's called
um or to throw out all of our money at
our debt and stay here for two years or
just turn up the tables go back to
Nebraska use our profit from the house
to to pay off all of our debt or I don't
really know what to do okay so I may
have missed that being a recall but what
caused you guys to go to Wichita in the
first place
well it's Southeast Kansas not really
Wichita oh I'm sorry okay but it doesn't
really matter uh it's Southeast Kansas
we have friends down here I've known
them for about 10 years we're looking at
buying a house we really wanted to buy
one
um if I would have found you guys sooner
I would have realized hey this is way
too soon we don't we're not ready for
this but we found a place out in the
country that was
um underpriced basically it was 15 acres
and it was underpriced and we decided
hey we have friends in that area
let's do this and we bought this house
down here so you moved truly just for
the house
yeah yeah okay and how far are you guys
from family now
like five hours oh wow so y'all like and
y'all are your jobs like local in Kansas
yes that we we got jobs she works at a
bank and I work at a an aircraft
manufacturing plant yeah and you're just
like this is not this wasn't as as
exciting and adventurous as it sounded
at the beginning now reality is set in
and you're thinking wow this isn't this
isn't fun now how how much Equity do you
have and how much debt do you have
um we well we bought the house for 225
um it was a five percent down payment so
there's 212 left and according to Zillow
I haven't had an appraised or anything
but according to Zillow and the houses
around this area it's worth about 260.
so before the real estate agent like
percentage and the taxes I'd be like
about 50 000 in the house okay okay so
you might walk away with closer to 30 on
this
yeah five okay and then how much debt do
you have
I I calculated it uh today it's about
twenty one thousand okay now you would
go back to Nebraska and rent for a while
absolutely okay I mean it sounds like a
good plan you don't have to move back to
Nebraska to get out of debt and so I
would only do it if there's a lot of
other reasons to do this and it sounds
like that reason is we don't like it
here we want to go back be closer to
family and part of that it's going to
help us get out of debt we're going to
rent for a year or two start saving up
and get into a house with some wisdom
and patience
yeah
that sounds good to me it sounds right
to me give me some peace just talking
that through
yeah and I know my wife's listening so I
I hope she uh found some peace in that
um because you both want to right
Jackson like y'all want out yeah we do
yeah and it's a great place down here
there's a lot of land were you super
happy in Nebraska because I feel like
there's a reason you left there to begin
with Beyond just there's a great house
in Kansas
um honestly if I think back uh we were
pretty happy we're in a little apartment
uh I think we just wanted to get into a
bigger space the apartment was like
you're probably going back to an
apartment in Nebraska yeah so I'm just
saying I don't know that you're going to
be in a much better spot other than
being debt free so I just want to make
sure that we get to the root of the
problem because you go with it which is
great because I think too though part of
the discontentment is like we want
something bigger and then when you get
something bigger and not doing it well
financially you're like oh wow maybe it
was better
back in a smaller place actually in
control of our money so it's kind of
almost like you learned your lesson
which is great it was not a fatal move
you guys are not like on the brink of
bankruptcy or foreclosure so you're good
you're in a good spot
um but so yeah I mean I think a lot of
the decisions in life it's agreeing with
your spouse is huge financially doesn't
make sense do we just want to our desire
do we want to do this and when all those
things kind of check off uh the boxes it
feels like a right move and I feel like
we just kind of checked all those off in
this call Jackson so to me I think it
would be worth it and I think it's an
exciting place for you guys because
you're going to be debt free you're
actually going to have about nine
thousand dollars in the bank saved that
you guys can work for an Emer you know
that can be your emergency fund you guys
are going to start these new habits with
money you're going to build up a down
payment because I know you want to own a
home again uh one day in Nebraska and
you're going to be able to uh here in a
few years doing it the right way it's
just going to be a different experience
you could just chalk this up to a
learning experience and it might be a
wash after you pay your capital gains
taxes on the profits so make sure hold
the money back but at least you'll leave
this thing completely debt free and back
to the place that you want to be closer
to family so I call that an overall win
that's great Jackson and it's a great
it's a it's so it's so interesting
because I think in life and we all do
this
but you have this thing of oh gosh you
know like if we just if we did that like
we want a bigger place so it all made
sense the motivation but when things
don't line up well specifically with
money we'll look through just that lens
right now
that it's not a smart move financially
it takes the whole exciting experience
and puts a lot of weight on it and all
of a sudden you're thinking oh God that
was not good and now our life is shrunk
down because we have no margin yeah and
now it's more stressful than ever and
it's just not worth it to discontentment
is contentment but often we go the
antidote is we see that house we need
that car we need this kind of life if I
can just do that yep I know it's never
the answer Jackson thanks for calling
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
second chronicles 15 7 but as for you be
strong and do not give up for your work
will be rewarded
the difference between winning and
losing is most off is most often not
quitting from Walt Disney thanks for
putting a Disney quote in there for me
guys loves Disney I do enjoy Disney
future episode of smart money happy hour
by the way we just recorded yesterday we
both have very different thoughts about
Disney and Disney adults in Disney World
and in the middle class
still make it to Disney World
a lot of there's a lot of a lot of
opinions out there it was therapeutic
for me Rachel really I shared my Disney
trauma George I had a traumatic
childhood experience I felt like Dr John
deloney on the show for a hot second and
I thought I feel like I need to like
walk him through this process of grief
and like I don't I don't know what's
happening a lot of stages there was a
lot a lot and that'll be a future
episode of smart money happy hour
already podcast this is a great time to
remind people if you haven't checked it
out yet just released yesterday first
two episodes and it's great because you
can listen over the weekend it's easy
listening very casual they're about 30
minutes apiece and it's at number one in
business number 32 overall so thank you
all for listening subscribing sending us
feedback posting about it telling your
friends it's a great casual money
conversation yes all that helps yes it
helps our egos saying number one it's
very nice
no no I'm not always number one but when
you when you get these kind of charts
even if you like for a book right when
you hit a bestseller was all of it
obviously yes it feels great as the
author or the podcast host to see that
but also the most important is it gets
it in front of other people other people
that never would have known can click on
it and we want to sneak them into this
whole thing that we're doing to help
them to say hey hey plug in the Ramsay
Solutions because then eventually
hopefully they go through Financial
Peace University they use every dollar
they read Dr John zaloni's stuff and
helps with their anxiety you just
because our mission is to help people in
every area of life and give them hope
and so uh it's just a great it's a great
way for people that normally wouldn't
have noticed us to notice us and it
validates the team's effort I mean we
are such a small part of making this
podcast happen there's like 40 people we
didn't post yesterday the amount of
people it takes to launch something and
the amount of work they've put in for
months and months and months from The
Producers to social media to
photographers and designers we just have
such a talented team so I'm proud of
them for all the work they put in to get
us here it's a very small absolutely
absolutely so great so check it out
smart money happy hour all right up next
we have Heather in San Antonio hey
Heather welcome to the show
hi thank you both uh for taking my call
today and thanks to the the bigger
Ramsey team for bringing my family peace
uh my question is part career and part
Financial some context
I'm 47 my husband is 52. uh this goes
back to the the quote from Disney about
quitting um it might I may have missed
out on that
um we are debt free except for a
mortgage we actually became debt free in
May of 21 thanks to the Ramsey plan
congratulations from thank you we moved
from California uh which was very
expensive to Texas uh just in May of
this year and um I have been working in
education more than 20 years but I'm not
working anymore I left a very nice
salary behind and I'm super grateful for
my husband supporting me and taking uh
and taking the time to essentially Catch
My Breath financially me not working is
not hurting us but it's not helping us
either I'm stuck I know I could get a
teaching or an administrator real easily
I did excel at my job but I
intentionally left education because I
was drowning my job left me feeling like
I was spiraling I
did we lose you Heather oh can you hear
me we just broke up just repeat the last
seven seconds
so you were you were spiraling out after
your education yeah and and I feel I
feel guilty that I'm not using my
credentials and that I'm not
contributing to our financial goals I
need to have purpose besides being a
great stay-at-home wife right now and I
want to start with volunteer work with
our new church by note listening to
Ramsey podcast while we were paying off
our debt actually led me to Jesus Christ
it was my first oh wow that's awesome
Heather love to hear that that's amazing
so um now that we're settled
I feel like I'm a human again
uh is that enough for now
am I being selfish by not getting a job
I'm not really retirement age if we do
end up moving again
um we believe his job is going to move
him in about two years will my work
employment gap be a problem if I do
decide to return to work should I be
worrying about those things right now
Heather what you guys have accomplished
in the last two years financially has
set you on a path where you have options
now in your life
you have options you get to decide what
do I want to do with my time what do I
want to do with my credentials what do I
want to do with my money all of that you
get options now because you guys have
worked to become debt free you don't owe
anyone anything your husband is making
um yeah you said a great salary
so you have options so this is this is
all up to you and I don't think the
conviction of going into a job comes out
of guilt and shame and that's what I'm
hearing that cycle play as you're
talking
um so I don't think that you are in a
spot that you're thinking in a very
healthy way because no that's not
selfish uh I mean I think that we have
the ability to to help people and to
serve and you've already given me two
options of things that you're thinking
about doing in that way which is great
and even if you wanted to take two years
off and just say I'm just gonna breathe
and I'm gonna go to lunch with some new
friends that I've met in San Antonio I'm
going to build community and
relationships and I that's okay like I
feel like you just need permission to
know that rest and a period of time it's
okay now if you're bored and you're
Restless you're like man I want to do
some things I want to put my brain in
function into uh you know part of my
life that I know I'm good at and I want
to go and work then that's one thing but
feeling guilted because you somehow told
yourself that you're selfish uh I don't
think is is a wise move no Heather you
are enough
period not if you go to work and not if
you volunteer you are enough
and now that you're a Believer you know
that you were created with a purpose and
if Ken was here he would say you're
created to contribute and that can look
different you can do that on your terms
but we're not going to do it out of
Shame and guilt because your husband's
working or because you feel like you
should be doing something outside of the
home and providing for your family or
using a piece of paper or using your 20
years of education experience so you get
the benefit of getting to do this all
over again on your terms and if that
means working part-time and volunteering
part-time that's great
but wherever this baggage is coming from
of my worth is tied up in my work we
gotta drop that because we have a new
vision for what the next 30 years of
your life looks like
so talk talk it up with your husband do
a dream date and go what do we want to
do what do I want to do what gifts do
you see in me and talents that I could
use to create impact to have that
purpose that I'm longing for do you guys
have kids Heather
and I'm college educated in debt breaks
so we don't have
yeah that's awesome that's awesome
uh when we say all that to you Heather
how does that feel
it it takes the burden you know this is
all my own self-doubt my husband is
super supportive he looks at me and and
is like well there's really not that you
don't have to go back to work I don't
know why you're so worried about it I
just um you know I've I've been very
driven uh since I was a young girl and
it feels weird to to feel like I'm not
yes and it would feel weird and it and I
think that that's a very normal thing
especially if it's you know if you think
if you've been working I have a friend
and she said she's been working since
she was 14 she got her first job at 14
and she's worked all the way through
High School through college through
adulthood all the way after having kids
I mean she's literally worked since she
was 14. and she took a break off and she
just said oh and and talking about this
is that that is weird because that's
called change and change is going to
feel weird to other whether you're a
stay-at-home mom and you go back into
the workforce or you're in the workforce
and you come home any change in our
lives it's going to feel weird so for it
to just feel normal uh that that's
probably not an option so the the
weirdness is very normal it doesn't make
it wrong though it doesn't make it wrong
so I hope that helps Heather just to
release you from that I think George's
words were perfect you are your value
comes from so much more now if you want
to jump in there and use your brain
because you want to that's great but
there's no pressure you don't have to
you get options because of the work that
you guys have done well thanks America
for listening thanks to Ben Zach Andrew
James everyone in the booth and Jenna
little girl
the only two only two women here in this
little Studio it's great and thank you
America for listening thanks George
appreciate it great weekend
[Music]
thank
you
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]